The Executive Director
of UNICEF said
Monday before the UN Security Council,
more than eighty children are killed or injured
every day in Gaza.
You and your
government have made the
choice to supportinconditionnellement
the government of Netanyahu.
In 1 democracy,
it's the right.
For others,
and they are many to think,
to say,
that the carnage must stop immediately,
an immediate ceasefire is needed throughout the world,
especially in Europe,
like in London,
very powerful demonstrations take place in France.
These events are prohibited
as was the case last Saturday in Paris.
Madam Prime Minister,
why this untenable position is incomprehensible.
In reality,
1 dangerous climate is being established,
dangerous for the country.
Democracy is slow,
center of civil liberties,
at the Rassemblement National.
And in your majority,
some thought it best to
take to the freedom of the press,
to target FP
and to decide to have it withdrawn
its public subsidies.
1 other member of your majority
adding as a real threat in this last object,
says on the radio,
Jean-Luc Mélenchon is a danger for society,
it should be done
If you disassociate
you clearly from his irresponsible remarks.
The first victim of a war.
And the truth,
it's true every time,
it is,
especially in shelled Gaza,
silenced,
28 journalists who were killed.
2 forums have just been published
requesting the French authorities
to call for protection.
Journalists
who try to
only to work in the enclave
to make their job informed.
Are you taking this call on your own?
So many questions related to this requirement that,
for our part,
we have been clamoring for each other since the beginning.
Cease the immediate fire!